it's friday night and you're thinking
about having a few drinks
only problem is it's quarantined in
march 2020 and all the liquor stores are
closed
so what do you do it just so happens you
have a bottle of rubbing alcohol in your
medicine cabinet
mix it with some soda and you have
yourself a well-made cocktail
false what you've just made is a
potentially fatal drink and goes without
saying you should never do this
but why can't you drink rubbing alcohol
after all it's just
alcohol right well yes and no there's
two types of alcohol you can buy
the kind you drink either as spirits
wine or beer and the kind you clean with
rubbing alcohol at one time both of
these were made using the same alcohol
molecule
ethanol however they were manufactured
differently due to government mandates
the federal government gets tax revenue
from the purchase of consumable alcohol
the higher the price the higher the
taxes and the more revenue it gets
and in case you didn't know people like
to drink if the same alcohol was
available at a drugstore for a fraction
of the cost
people would buy this instead to drink
and the government would lose out on tax
revenue
it couldn't make rubbing alcohol illegal
because it's an industrial solvent and a
disinfectant
to fix this it was mandated that rubbing
alcohol have ingredients added to it to
discourage consumption
namely a bitter agent denatonium
benzoate and a poison
usually methanol as you can imagine this
didn't work
people especially during prohibition
were either trying to purify the ethanol
or just drink it straight
as a result many people died from the
poisonous additives
to make it easier on everyone else
manufacturers switch the alcohol
molecule from
ethanol a two carbon alcohol to propanol
or isopropyl alcohol
a three carbon alcohol see this was a
great solution
no longer was the same type of alcohol
being sold in liquor and drug stores
thereby resolving the tax revenue issue
lethal additives no longer had to be
added because the isopropyl alcohol
itself was
unsafe to drink now the majority of
rubbing alcohol you buy at the drugstore
is the 70
isopropyl alcohol solution though
ethanol based is still sold it's
produced much less
so how unsafe is this 70 isopropyl
alcohol to drink
well it's not as dangerous as methanol
but not as safe as drinking ethanol
when you drink ethanol the molecule in
alcoholic beverages
it's metabolized into acetaldehyde which
is toxic
but then it's converted into acetic acid
which is safe
in contrast isopropyl alcohol is solely
converted into acetone
the same stuff you buy at the hardware
store that's used as paint thinner and
dissolved styrofoam
yeah this stuff oddly enough acetone is
only moderately toxic to the human body
meaning it takes more than just a few
milliliters to be lethal
the danger of acetone lies in the fact
that it's a highly potent nervous system
depressant
roughly three times stronger than
alcohol for example the lethal dose of
ethanol for a 150 pound man is about 300
milliliters
in contrast the lethal dose of acetone
for a man of the same weight
is just 100 milliliters less than half a
cup
because of its higher potency it's been
noted that acetone has narcotic-like
effects
and when taken in lethal doses it
produces the same effects of someone
undergoing severe alcohol poisoning
since the nervous system operates at a
slower capacity nerve signaling that
operates bodily functions
also slows down as well especially heart
rate this causes the breathing to slow
down
reduction in blood circulation causing
pale skin and slower metabolism which
drops the body temperature
all this leads to coma and then
but wait why is acetone more poisonous
than ethanol
as the acetone sits in the body it
depresses the nervous system until it's
excreted in the urine
in contrast ethanol is first reduced to
something safer and then later excreted
which lessens the depressant effects
while it's in the body
this fact is why acetone is a stronger
depressant than
ethanol it takes less time to reduce the
toxin than it does to excrete it
while the ethanol is in the body it gets
reduced to a less toxic form
so over time the nervous system is less
depressed
however the whole time acetone stays in
the body it keeps depressing the nervous
system
until it's excreted still this is an
improvement from the methanol waste
rubbing alcohol
of the past just 15 milliliters of
methanol
is fatal where with acetone it takes up
to 100 milliliters
thereby people would have to drink more
to reach a fatal dose regardless
you should never drink rubbing alcohol
even if it's during quarantine and you
have nothing else to drink
stay safe everyone
you